hello and welcome to this video playing
p.m. address hoy dear milanos okay I
can't believe it gosh people seem to
have a desire to to just yeah play for
equality with widen I'm not even sure
that I mean right probably is equal to 0
but he has to fight for again this is
the Catalan reversed and the one move
down doesn't relieve doesn't really mean
all that much so he wants to play with
f4 here it seems make a reverse still
more all of it it's interesting at least
not totally stop it
okay so near 94 should be good ok so if
he allows that I'm happy he goes back
because if you have let space keep all
the pieces on the board of course not
but he's still plated I came this was a
bit bit too aggressive but I like to
punish this kind of play or at least try
okay so so send this night back ok so
right f6 them on yeah well maybe see for
what will that gradient I sort of hoped
for more the avid maybe this is too too
ambitious that I was hoping for more
than being slightly better we try to do
92 or I don't know this could be
interesting actually just yeah yeah try
to double and into buying some pieces
the night cannot move across the bishop
hangs yeah and is this sir we had moved
that might work it looks a little bit
strange because you normally don't want
to give up the bishop like that but
maybe it works okay Bishop takes half
Bishop h6 and here I can do this and
then enter okay
[Music]
we just this one present rupee 1h
forward quite weakening so now I'm
threatening h6 that we should have six
those things
I have you should check and all that
that doesn't get to all that much as I
think there should be six King edge
aight i don't think so let's see what
tasks like I played it ok I must be some
really cool technical point but I listen
you could have just gone back to f3
instead ok so do I trade now on trading
looks at EDD wrong maybe this one it
would be a better way to trade as i'm
preparing kingi 70 but the move i should
have spotted this is a game that i
already really hate yeah now you just I
just look so weird everything and then
you land disposition which doesn't
release which is pretty much nothing
awful play on me
and probably multiple ways to be
substantially better but I didn't find
any of them this is probably equal i try
to try to come around here with the
route we win win one of the queenside
pawns time money maybe you can try to
again move the rock end and enter but i
can always counter-attack the c3 porn
okay i know that looks very loose what
i'm doing here but maybe you can try
trading books will never help this would
be didn't actually see that king at five
was possible but okay at least he now
has to use one piece to stop the edge
pod and okk six it wasn't difficult
anyways for me to try something here
probably not him can switch this around
like four excellent unity young matter
was really bad game why should never get
to any solid position here but from this
is just dreadful and I should never yeah
allow him to get some kind of position
anymore probably c4 is too too close I
don't know a bishop age 60 is already
great yeah you cannot cover III Scott
this one they just cannot cover it
sensibly okay and this is wasn't so
great i mean really not okay now that
wasn't the phone from right here just
what it is and now he played the plate
plate okay Jack look completely bonkers
yeah so I should somehow win here but
don't ask me how we shall see aight what
i'm missing very simple moves at the
moment here we should see eight is not
exactly difficult okay the engine points
this out so this is fairly simple win
for black because and I'm very nicely
coordinated the bishop before keeps
everything Bishop coming that keeps
everything coordinated that's very good
and this I actually just missed this 96
idea yeah this is this will again
probably equal that's probably equal I
mean somehow you go to the situation
that I got the past service again this
should still be equal whether you just
always tell the time yeah it was pretty
pretty bad I was making a little bit of
fun there because you have to take on
this heaven of course now you have less
space you have to trade your your knife
day and keeping it on the board is just
completely entire positional but okay
this nd5 yeah that's why it is already
pretty much punished for its opening
playlet it really complied it really not
great at that
this was the cleanest one and no one we
can company cannot cover that anymore in
a sensible way okay guys thanks for
watching